last night Democrat John fetterman faced
off with Republican Dr Oz in the first
and only debate for one of the most
important Senate races in the country
and things did not go great for John
fetterman
as lieutenant governor you're running
for a seat that could decide the balance
of power in Washington what qualifies
you to be a U.S senator you have 60
Seconds
hi good night everybody
I'm running to serve Pennsylvania he's
running to use Pennsylvania
not a great way to start and fetterman's
performance only went downhill from
there I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show good night
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Stone Cold's
beer cooler who says I've got the eye of
the Pfizer
says Katy Perry now I'm not allowed
according to the rules of several of the
big social media Giants I'm not allowed
to suggest that the covid vaccines would
cause people's faces to go all kooky and
crazy and freeze up and become paralyzed
even though the NIH the National
Institutes of Health have have done
studies to this effect uh I I would I
would not suggest that I'm just singing
a catchy little lyric that one of the
viewers of this show happened to send in
really catchy though really interesting
really incisive you might even say
that's probably a very smart person
really a very employable person probably
who wrote that when you want to find
employable people you've got to check
out ZipRecruiter right now head on over
to ziprecruiter.com Knowles the midterm
elections are upon us I hope you are
ready to vote because all 435 seats and
ask representatives and 35 seats in the
Senate are up for grabs now of course we
need to fill those roles with the most
qualified people which is not an easy
task fortunately not every role has to
be that difficult to fill especially if
you're hiring for your business thanks
to ZipRecruiter ZipRecruiter does the
work for you and right now you can try
it for free at ziprecruiter.com Knowles
how does ZipRecruiter make hiring faster
and easier first when you post your job
unzip recruiter it uses powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job and sends
them to you then you can easily review
these recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply four out of
five employers who post on ZipRecruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day if you want a better way to find
great people for your team try
ziprecruiter.com Knowles at
ziprecruiter.com
ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s sip recruiter the smartest
way to hire
I knew that John Federman was in bad
shape
he was never the sharpest tool in the
shed he's always had extremely radical
terrible ideas for government for his
entire political career he's never held
a real productive job outside of the
government in his life he has been on
his parents Dole basically uh since he
was a little kid even in recent years he
received an allowance of fifty thousand
dollars plus per year to subsidize his
political meanderings and he said that
if he had a magic wand he would waive it
and the first thing he would do is free
murderers from prison so the guy was
always a complete disaster then right
around the time of his election uh to
become the the Democrat nominee during
the primaries he had a stroke and his
campaign has consistently downplayed how
bad the stroke was and tried to pretend
that he's had this amazing recovery now
I never believed any of that I always
knew John fetterman was in pretty bad
shape
I had no idea that he was in this bad of
shape uh
uh so we've got
uh I'll give you a few of the highlights
here there's no reason to go through the
whole debate I actually can't even watch
the whole debate it just you feel you
actually feel bad for the guy you really
want to the first feeling you have is I
really don't want this guy in the U.S
Senate but the second feeling you have
is like this guy needs to be in a bed
somewhere just recovering so he's asked
first question okay uh Mr fetterman you
have previously said that you oppose
fracking now as the race gets close in
the general election you say you support
fracking which is it here's his answer
Mr Oz I do want to clarify something
you're saying tonight that you support
fracking that you've always supported
fracking but there is that 2018
interview that you said quote I don't
support fracking at all so how do you
square the two
oh I I I do support fracking and
I don't I don't
I support fracking and I stand and I do
support fracking
that's in his defense that's probably
the best answer he could possibly give
because there there is no explanation he
has been consistent in his entire career
he said we actually have we have the
clips of it it's much worse even than
the moderator suggested John fetterman
if he has been consistent on anything in
his career it's how much he opposes
fracking
I I I've always supported fracking I
don't support fracking at all and I
never have um yeah I called for
moratorium on frackings there's no such
thing as a green fracker I'm not
pro-fracking 2016 fracking moratorium
pledge that fetterman signed for an
environmental Watchdog group as well as
a 2016 tweet he sent while running for
U.S Senate I don't uh support fracking I
I think it's something that has to
eventually go away uh and I would like
to see it you know transition out
[Music]
so even you can't really blame this on
the stroke or anything like that this
was a very cynical political decision to
lie by fetterman's campaign and what's
really sad about this on the debate
stage is even while the campaign genius
strategists they're saying okay we're
going to lie and we're going to
completely flip your position on
fracking to get you through the general
election then you can go back to your
old one then he goes on stage and this
man who just it is not mentally present
it would take a good politician a lot of
skill to be able to Jujitsu that
particular flip-flop but for someone
whose brain isn't working it's just not
possible then fetterman was asked about
certain tax problems here's his answer
Mr fetterman I will allow a 15 second
rebuttal he has specifically said you
have not paid your taxes and that you
want to raise taxes on Americans how do
you respond uh absolutely the Oz rule of
course he's lying it was helping two
students 17 years ago to help them you
know buy their own homes they they
didn't pay the bills and it got her paid
and it has never been an issue in in any
of the campaign before
it was all about non-profit
I don't even know how to respond to that
it's just completely incoherent
gibberish again really really sad stuff
and then I thought actually the saddest
moment of the entire night was not one
of the moments when fetterman was asked
to give an answer but when Dr Oz was
giving an answer and then fetterman just
burst out out of nowhere with some
completely unrelated comment
relative states to do what they wish to
do the abortion decision should be left
up the states and specifically when John
Farrell along with Doug Mr
so
oh man so Dr Oz is answering a question
about abortion and where he thinks the
abortion issue should be decided at the
federal level or at the state level and
kind of what his views are on abortion
which are actually quite confusing so
it's a good question to act ask Dr Oz
and then just out of nowhere Federman
says you roll with mastriano who's the
he's the Republican nominee for governor
of Pennsylvania we interviewed him on
this show yesterday just
very sad stuff
I know a number of stroke victims I
suspect many of you know or have at
least met stroke victims
Fetter I'm not saying fetterman is the
worst off stroke victim I've ever met
but he's definitely in the bottom 50 in
terms of people who have made a recovery
I'm just saying this anecdotally of
people I know who have suffered from the
same thing that this guy has suffered
from this guy is in terrible terrible
shape and so I think I mean this was the
number one trend on Twitter this morning
was stroke this is really shocking even
to people who have followed this race
pretty closely like those of you
listening to the show I suspect this is
really really bad stuff so people are
saying well he's not fit to do the job
of a senator and on that point I'm
actually not so sure
and I'm not even making a joke about how
Senators brains don't function properly
that's not the joke I'm making the point
I'm making is that the job of a senator
is not what it used to be
if John fetterman were running for the
Senate 50 years ago 100 years ago 150
years ago then I would say absolutely
there's no way this guy's up to the job
of a senator because Senators used to
have a lot of power Senators used to
have a lot of responsibility the
individual Senators used to matter quite
a lot
over the last hundred years a lot of
that power has been taken away a lot of
that power has been usurped by the
federal bureaucracy Senators don't
really make all that many laws anymore
the foreign policy which Senators used
to have a fair amount of say over
because they had the power
to ratify treaties and and declare war a
lot of that has been usurped Again by
the executive branch so it doesn't even
really matter so much there and then the
parties have become so deeply entrenched
in in their own camps at this point
they've become so polarized that very
often the the individual Senators don't
really matter it's our system is moving
more toward a parliamentary type system
where the individuals aren't as
important as just an r or a d next to
somebody's name to go in line with the
caucus so in terms of that
responsibility John fetterman's probably
perfectly qualified to be a senator
not according to the letter of the
Constitution not according to the
traditional role of a senator but if
he's just there to be the 51st vote for
Chuck Schumer I guess he could do that
he's not going to know what room he's in
or what Bill he's voting on but his his
staff can lift up his arm and have him
sign something or push a button they can
do that very very easily and so I
suspect a lot of Democrats in
Pennsylvania are going to think that I
don't think the debate last night
changed one Democrat vote in
Pennsylvania and I don't think it
changed one Republican vote necessarily
except for the the hardcore
conservatives who were so skeptical of
Oz because he's fairly liberal and they
were maybe considering okay should I not
vote for us you look at that guy you say
goodness gracious he's just so bad off
maybe maybe now I'm more inclined for
for uh Dr Oz the people that this will
have affected are those undecided voters
are the people who are not firmly
partisan
and who don't vote simply on fracking
abortion immigration you know just that
handful of issues where they've got
really clear views there there is a huge
portion of the American electorate which
does not pay super close attention to
politics like those of you listening to
this show right now who don't have a
particularly systematic view of of
looking at politics and it's not even
their own fault they're probably they've
got more interesting things in their
lives and they care more about you know
their hobbies and their work and their
families and they're just not they're
just not political nerds paying
attention to this stuff and so they're
going to look at these much more human
characteristics and they're just going
to look at these two guys and you say
okay on the one hand we've got a sick
patient on the other hand we've got got
a guy who's literally a doctor I think
I'm going to vote for that guy so
there's no no question no matter how sad
this debate was a clear win for Dr Oz it
may or may not affect the the final
outcome because they've had early voting
in Pennsylvania since September but as
Doug mastriano the governor candidate
pointed out to us yesterday early voting
mail-in voting is way way down this year
compared to 2020. so overall I think the
odds campaign has to be very very happy
with the the outcome of the debate and I
think the Democrats and the people who
put fettermen up to this should be
absolutely ashamed of themselves you
know
someday all these political problems are
going to pass away as far as we're
concerned because we're going to die
we're all going to die no one here gets
out alive that's why you've got to get a
will that's why you got to check out
epic will right now head on over to
epicwill.com Knowles what do you and
your family hold dear your faith church
on Sunday do you believe in serving
other people did you give your kids that
fouchy ouchy or did you say I don't
think so how does your family Define men
and women what kind of value do they put
on life your children look to you to
Define how they view the world what they
hold dear what they value but what if
you were not there to do that for them
in the event that you die who will
ensure that what you hold dear will be
upheld by your kids epic will can help
with that a will lets you determine who
will raise your kids in the event that
you die before you're done raising them
this is a big deal and it's a
responsibility that you have as a parent
it's why we at the daily wire have
partnered with epic will go to
epicwill.com and use promo code Knolls
knowns to save 10 on Epic Will's
complete will package and more
importantly so that I know you did it so
that you're accountable to me okay
epicwill.com promo code Knowles
John fetterman was not the only Democrat
candidate who collapsed on stage last
night Kathy hokel who is uh running who
is the governor of New York and running
for reelection as governor of New York
she was debating Lee zeldon who's doing
great he's the Republican candidate and
and he's actually
according to certain polls ahead of her
you know in True Blue New York so there
was one huge misstep that Kathy hokel
made last night I think that Lee zeldin
very smartly kept pressing the crime
issue I spoke yesterday to Doug
mastriano mastriano said that in
Pennsylvania the biggest issue is crime
and I think so many people all around
the country
forget about abortion forget about even
certain economic issues and immigration
the top issue for a lot of people
especially in the cities is crime
because crime is spiking people are
fearing for their property and fearing
for their lives so the Republicans are
hitting this issue and Kathy hokel gave
the worst answer I could imagine on
crime
who's still to this moment where we
through the debate
shouldn't talked about locking up anyone
committing any crimes okay anyone who
commits a crime under our laws
especially with the change they made to
bail has consequences I don't know why
that's so important
I don't know why it's so important to
you Lee
why uh late oh goodness gracious you're
just such a knuckle dragging idiot why
is it so important to you that we put
the criminals in jail
just oh goodness gr I don't have any
criminals storming my Mansion I don't
know what's wrong with you Lee goodness
gracious let's talk about important
things like how we have to chop the
genitals off of children
goodness graciously let's talk about
important things like the need to kill
more babies but no Lee you've just got
to go on and on about locking up the
rapists and the murderers who are
running in Havoc all over New York ah
gosh get a gripley can you imagine
you're a regular New Yorker listening to
this
you're a regular New Yorker and let's
say you're in the city you're in a city
that has had difficulties with crime
over the years and you're seeing a spike
in crime right now and your governor
who's asking for your vote says oh
forget about the crime enough with the
crime so dumb we don't need to put the
criminals into prison come on send a
social worker whatever don't move on how
out of touch do you need to be
a huge misstep now she's in a tough
position because the Democrats are
totally split on this the base wants to
empty the prisons the base spent the
last year talking about how they need to
defund the police and abolish prisons
and it wasn't just The Fringe extreme
activist lunatics it was sitting members
of Congress some some of whom are from
New York okay it was it was very
prominent Democrat politicians
openly calling to defund the police and
abolish federal prisons okay
so you got that on the base side but
then you've got the normal people who
want to do exactly the opposite they
want to increase funding to believe but
they want to increase funding to the
police and they want to put more
criminals into prison because the
criminals are wreaking havoc in their
communities
so what does Kathy hokel do she's trying
to split that baby you can't split that
baby and if she were smart she would say
no listen we're doing a great job we're
doing a great job of putting criminals
into prison we're going to do an even
better job
next year and move on but you can't do
that and it's a major major win for the
Republicans just shows you once again
how completely out of touch the
Democrats are right now with the
electorate so what if what are they
going to do they know they're headed for
disaster if it's a fair election so what
are they going to do
this is the greatest irony of all after
spending
two years
lambasting Republicans calling us
fascists and Nazis and an existential
threat to our democracy for questioning
in any way the legitimacy of the 2020
election
the Democrats the very top Democrats the
most prominent Democrats in the country
are preemptively
questioning and outright denying
potentially the legitimacy of the 2022
and 2024 elections Hillary take it away
hello indivisibles I'm here to highlight
something that is keeping me up at night
and I know this group really understands
what I'm about to say
I know we're all focused on the 2022
midterm elections and they are
incredibly important
but we also have to look ahead
because you know what our opponents
certainly are
right-wing extremists already have a
plan to literally steal the next
presidential election and they're not
making a secret of it
the right wing controlled Supreme Court
may be poised to rule on giving State
legislatures Yes you heard me that
correctly State legislatures the power
to overturn presidential elections
just think if that happens the 2024
presidential election
could be decided not by the popular vote
or even by the anachronistic electoral
college
but by state legislatures
so much there
most obvious
she's saying that the Republicans are
going to steal the election if the
Republicans win it will be because they
stole the election which is what the
Democrats believe and the Democrats
believe this because they believe that
they're on the right side of history and
they believe that democracy is just
synonymous with liberalism so even
though democracy means the will of the
people and sometimes the people vote for
your party and sometimes the people vote
for the other party they they don't view
democracy in that way they they use the
word democracy to really just mean
liberalism and so when liberalism is
rejected at The Ballot Box that is a
knock against democracy even if the
majority of people vote for that and so
she she is already saying as the
Democrats have said as Hillary Clinton
herself has said for many many years
if the Republicans win the election by
definition is illegitimate because the
people are supposed to vote for the
Democrats the people if they
were not being suppressed and not being
misinformed and not having their
Consciousness lowered you know they have
to raise their Consciousness and raise
the awareness they were not operating
under a false consciousness if all those
things
were true
they would vote for the Democrats
they would because that's obviously the
right thing to do
so anytime they don't it has to be
illegitimate by definition she's already
saying that
and then she's going through all the
different ways in which it could be
illegitimate and then the little cherry
on top of the irony sundae is that she
said and could you believe the election
won't be decided potentially by the
popular vote
or even the anachronistic electoral
college
the the Electoral College whatever you
think of it
is not anachronistic
it is it's not out of time
the Electoral College is the way
currently today in the year of Our Lord
2022 and for the entire history of our
country that presidential elections have
been decided
it's not anachronistic it's the law it's
the Constitution it is the very heart of
that particular aspect of our supposedly
sacred democracy that the Democrats are
always talking about
the popular vote has absolutely nothing
to do with the presidential election
therefore it's not how the campaigns are
conducted it's not how it's just not
part of it at all but because
the Democrats sometimes have won the
popular vote but lost the electoral vote
then they just they just go for that so
the even in that language even in their
their
absurd elevation of the popular vote
over the actual way the elections are
conducted according to our constitution
even there they are denying the
legitimacy of our electoral system after
two years
of saying that we are Fascist threats to
the country where the equivalent of
murderers or the equivalent of
terrorists we need to be completely
sidelined for questioning our electoral
system that's the best they've got
now if this is going to be a really
tough one for the for the Democrats
because
not only are the polls looking really
really bad for the Democrats right now
but voter enthusiasm seems relatively
high so usually in the midterms voter
turnout is much lower than in a
presidential election year that's pretty
much always the case it'll probably be
the case again but voter turnout seems
to be pretty okay right now at least
according to early metrics so a reporter
asked White House Press Secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre about this said you know you
guys keep talking about voter
suppression but the numbers show that
voter turnout is actually looking pretty
good right now what say you Kareem
Jean-Pierre
the access to voting is being attacked
but doesn't that record turnout show
that Georgia voters are finding ways to
vote even amid the with the uh yeah I'm
not going to get into specifics of what
Georgia voters are doing what I am
saying is that uh you know generally
speaking again more broadly speaking of
course High turnout and voter
suppression can take place at the same
time
hold on a second here I
I don't have a fancy degree in political
science I don't work in the white house
or anything like that
but
it seems to me
that voter suppression means less voting
right that's
vote voter someone who casts a vote and
suppression means you kind of push it
down
right and then High voter turnout is
when you get more voting
and what Kareem Jean-Pierre is actually
saying with a straight face is that less
voting and more voting can happen at the
same time
that's what they that's their final
pitch when every other strategy when
every other excuses run out that's the
that's the they can say it's
illegitimate
this is voter suppression
it's unfair and every every single
argument they're making is collapsing
but they've got their story and they're
sticking to it and they don't give one
single damn is to any of the facts all
of the facts that contradict all of it
why are the people voting for the
Republicans why are all the polls
showing the Republicans way way up
a whole host of reasons
but one of the big ones
right now economic discontent is at an
all-time high in the United States not
just wow this is much worse than it was
under Trump not just wow this is even
worse than it wasn't to Obama all time
ever
this is according to a new survey by NBC
News 71 percent of registered voters say
the nation under Democrat rule is on the
wrong track that is a record high
disapproval only 20 percent say the
nation is on the right track
57 percent disapprove of Biden's
handling of the economy that is another
record high
57 disapprove 38 percent
approve
50 percent say the Democrats economy
will get worse that is another record
high only 20 believe the economy will
improve so you you can you can't blame
this here on it's a conservative poll
that went out no it's NBC News you can't
blame it on well it's just the wording
of the question they worded the question
three different ways every single time
it's a record high
at people right now and people do vote
in large part on the economy people do
vote on kitchen table issues and we are
now at record high economic discontent
so the Democrats they have to answer
this in some way they've got to answer
this in the final two weeks here before
the midterm elections
and here is the here is the best
argument I've heard the best response
from the Democrats this would be via
Pete bootage on the Stephen Colbert Show
it can be
frustrating politically yeah when you
see that sort of stuff go on but you
know look this is this is part of a
pattern that we've often seen where
uh many uh Congressional Republicans
take stances that seem to be more about
the problem than about the solution so
you know you look at even the things
that they talk about the most often uh
immigration inflation I mean name of all
the things Congressional Republicans
have proposed policy wise can anybody
name the top five things that they've
suggested to fight inflation can anyone
name three how about one you know they
voted no on the inflation reduction act
it was about lowering prices for
Americans and I would have loved nothing
more than to have a debate between the
Democratic or inflation reduction Act
and the Republican inflation reduction
act on the house of the Florence Senate
and argued over which one was better but
there was only one and it was ours and
luckily it passed well you couldn't have
that debate Pete because there was no
Democrat inflation reduction act there
was an act called the inflation
reduction Act
but it did nothing to reduce inflation
and that's not just me as a Republican
or a conservative arguing that that's
what the CBO said the Congressional
budget office said that the inflation
reduction act would not reduce inflation
Bernie Sanders admitted that the
inflation reduction act would not reduce
inflation Joe Biden and the Democrats
tacitly admitted that because the second
that that act passed they stopped
referring to it as an inflation act and
they started referring to it as a
climate change act because that's what
it was really about was just passing on
hundreds and hundreds of billions of
dollars in handouts to Green energy
companies and then he says well you know
the Republicans
they haven't offered their solution
they're not they're not fixing the
problem Democrats have Unified
Government it's not even like the
Republicans had to work with the
Democrats to get anything done
Democrats had completely Unified
Government so the problem is 100 at your
feet and you screwed it up and you're
saying well how come the Republicans
didn't do more to stop us from screwing
it up when they had no political power
but that's the best answer you've got
and he says well they have no ideas
they have no ideas that I couldn't name
two one idea three ideas five ideas that
the Republicans have
okay well here's my first one speaking
of that bill that you were that law that
you were just naming here's one way that
you could slow down inflation a little
bit
don't spend 400 billion dollars in
taxpayer handouts to Democrat cronies in
the green energy industry
don't waste all that money and
frivolously spend that money which which
causes inflation to rise don't do that
that would be my first idea what are
some other ideas I don't know see just
off the top of my head here
um don't forgive forgive quote unquote
student loans don't just pass out all of
that money and cause inflation to ride
what would be some other ideas I don't
know maybe stop escalating the war in
Ukraine the war in Ukraine which is
probably the primary driver of inflation
and was caused largely by Joe Biden
according to Vladimir zielinski who's
the president of Ukraine because Joe
Biden took the sanctions off of Putin's
Pipeline and then literally invited
Putin to invade eastern Ukraine and said
that if there were only a minor
incursion there would be no serious
response from the United States so that
would be one idea on on that point okay
so I got what is that that's three ideas
you could restart American energy
production how about that remember we
had great American energy production
under Donald Trump we were energy
independent we were a net exporter under
Donald Trump and then Biden comes in and
he kills all the new oil and gas leases
and he kills the oil pipelines and by
the way when you kill one major oil
pipeline from the federal government
you're effectively killing all of them
for for the remainder of the
administration
is the people who are building these
pipelines are only going to do it if
they've got political support they're
very very expensive projects so you
could do that I would be I would I mean
energy is the biggest driver of
inflation right now so that would be a
really good idea how about I don't know
whether that's for don't revive the Iran
nuclear deal that would be another good
one why is Saudi Arabia not playing ball
right now with the United States why is
Saudi Arabia not going to pump out way
more oil and try to bring the prices
back to something that's somewhat
reasonable well in large part it's
because the United States gave Saudi
Arabia the middle finger when the United
States started cozying up to Iran again
because the Democrats have this bizarre
obsession
with putting Iran on the path to a
nuclear bomb which Saudi Arabia will not
permit and so now now we've lost the
Saudis
as the close Ally that we've had for so
many years that's five there it is
there's your five ideas Pete
I got not that any of those are going to
go into effect because the Democrats
have Unified Government they caused the
whole problem and now they're dealing
with the consequences of that which is
that the people are absolutely freaking
Furious and so now what are the
Democrats going to say about that
we've gone we've gone through every
single argument that they've got and
every response to it and then they keep
digging themselves into worse and worse
trouble so now now here is the argument
people who are extremely concerned about
record high inflation which is
impoverishing everybody and it's going
to cause people to freeze as the winter
approaches now the Democrats are saying
that if you're worried about inflation
you might as well vote for Hitler
I'm not calling I'm not going to say
that you know the GOP or Nazis at this
point or whatever but it certainly
sounds very familiar to what happened in
Germany which is a bunch of citizens
today Adolf Hitler gets a third of the
vote nobody thought it could happen
there they kind of went along because
they said he was going to solve the
economy and fix inflation yeah that's
right did you can hear those sorts of
things and then oh lo and behold a few
years later they lost their democracy
and they're all like how'd that happen
here that's my worry that is my worry if
obviously the price of a hamburger the
price of milk the the price of gas is
concerning but what is what that is a
short-term problem the loss of a
democracy will decimate everyone's
freedom
that's it if you
if you are concerned about the record
high inflation and the fact that you
can't fill up your gas tank or heat your
home
uh you or or pay for groceries or pay
for anything because it's causing all
the consumer goods to increase you you
look I'm not calling you a Nazi but
tacitly I am okay and you secretly you
would have voted for Hitler okay and
you're gonna call if you elect
Republicans
you're going to cause us to lose our
democracy
because whenever the people vote against
the ruling party whenever the people
want to change in the ruling party from
the liberal establishment Democrat
ruling class that's a threat to
democracy
by the way you know the man who said
that that's Matthew Dowd
he is a Democrat but he
formerly was a Republican and not just a
regular old Republican strategist you
sometimes see that title on TV which
usually just means unemployed political
person strategy everyone's just a
strategist you know but this guy
actually had a real job this guy was the
chief strategist for the bush Cheney
2004 campaign
this guy was a big player he he was
obviously a court jester conservative he
was obviously one of the squishes whose
job it is to pretend to be right wing to
legitimize the dominant liberal regime
but he had that Big R next to his name
he had a pretty big job
and he is now making the same argument
that all of the Democrats are making
which is
any any time you oppose us you're
basically Hitler and anytime the
Republicans win it's it's a threat to
democracy
and anytime we let the people vote for
the people they want it's it's a threat
to democracy by the way just a side
point
I would like to call
for a complete moratorium on Nazi
comparisons I I am calling for a
complete and total shutdown on all Nazi
comparisons until we figure out what the
hell is going on there it's so it's so
frustrating
and it's it's not frustrating because
you know World War II is is incomparable
or anything like that
it's frustrating because what when when
I hear people make Nazi comparisons what
that says to me is that that person has
no other historical frame of reference
so very often I think people make the
Nazi comparisons because they just don't
know
what else to compare something to
the the the second version of this is
the fall of Rome which is much more
acceptable
but you know there there were other Wars
there have been other Wars throughout
history folks okay there have been other
battles there how about uh I don't know
the Battle of Waterloo comparison how
about that make some comparisons to the
Napoleonic Wars at least how about that
is that okay how about the the French
and Indian war that would be a good one
let's compare things to the French and
Indian War
or I don't know Alexander the Great's
campaigns
for the uh you know Wars against
Carthage
I don't know or the Peloponnesian War or
any anything other than just making
everything about Hitler okay it's not
not every not not every person that you
don't like is Hitler okay and it but but
because
Hitler is
forget about the second world war itself
Hitler just is the symbol of the
absolute incarnation of evil and so when
when what the Democrats are doing here
is they're saying anyone who opposes us
is the absolute perfect incarnation of
evil that must be opposed at all costs
regardless of the law regardless of
Justice regardless of anything
and speaking of these Hitler comparisons
because look I don't mean to be too hard
on people who make who have made Hitler
comparisons I've brought everyone's done
it at some point but
the
there was a recent example of this that
shows you just how disingenuous the
whole debate is Susan Sarandon
just posted something to social media
comparing her opponents to Hitler Susan
Sarandon is a very far left-wing actress
Susan Sarandon said it didn't start with
the gas Chambers it started with one
party controlling the media one party
controlling the message one party
deciding what is truth one party
censoring speech and silencing
opposition one party dividing citizens
into us and them and calling on their
supporters to harass them started when
good people turned a blind eye and let
that happen
now it's interesting when I read that if
I saw someone post that today I would
assume they were talking about the
Democrats
who the Liberals obviously control
the media and the government all the
rest of it and they censor people and
but Susan Sarandon so far left wing I
don't think that's what but who knows
right anyway Susan serene's very
left-wing actress
now Susan Sarandon
will just go about her life normally
nothing will happen as a result of this
post
Gina Carano our friend Gina Carano
lost her job and nearly lost her entire
career
for making pretty much the same post
Gina Carano posted Jews were beaten in
the streets not by Nazi soldiers but by
their neighbors even by children because
history's edited most people re today
don't realize that to get to the point
where Nazi soldiers could easily Round
Up thousands of Jews the government
first made their own neighbors hate them
simply for being Jews how's that any
different from some hating someone for
their political views so it's virtually
the same exact post
and Gina Carano it very implausibly was
called an anti-semite for me it seems
like completely the opposite of the sort
of sentiment she was expressing
but it was the same poster Susan
Sarandon so why does Gina Carano who is
a little more right-wing almost lose her
career for this and Susan Sarandon who
is very left-wing nothing happens to her
just a reminder that our rulers they
they don't care about anti-Semitism or
racism or any of the lines that they use
the the libs had exhibited much more
anti-Semitism than anybody on the right
including City members of Congress
including ilhan Omar to use just one
example including Louis Farrakhan
visiting the Congressional Black Caucus
Barack Obama taking a smiling picture
with him Louis Farrakhan calling the
Jews the synagogue of Satan and and many
other lurid things the list goes on and
on and on
much worse than anything any mainstream
person on the right has ever said it
doesn't matter
forget about the racism the racism you
see from the left obviously so much
worse than anything you've ever seen
anywhere in the mainstream right
our rulers don't care about those things
for themselves
are our ruling class
uses those Concepts as an excuse to
destroy people that they already don't
like and have already decided to destroy
they use it because it is convenient to
silence dissenters which is why they're
not going to silence the liberals who
basically go along with their agenda
they're always going to use it to
silence the right Wingers you know it's
been a very very busy month over here at
the daily wire
we released the greatest lie ever sold
which is a new documentary that buries
BLM we held a rally to end child
mutilation at the Tennessee State
Capitol and we are hours away from
another exciting event daily wire
backstage you can join me Ben Shapiro
Matt Walsh Andrew Clayton the god king
Jeremy boring tonight 6 p.m Central 7
P.M Eastern we'll be talking midterms
leftist meltdowns and a whole lot more
it is a backstage you do not want to
miss so tune in tonight daily wire
plus.com
here's a great example
of the libs
disingenuously
silencing victims
weeks after Alex Jones was ordered by a
judge
to pay about one billion dollars to the
family of the Sandy Hook shooting
victims
Bloomberg News is reporting that the
Sandy Hook families have have now
demanded
2.75 trillion dollars
an additional 2.75 trillion dollars
not all that far off from the GDP of the
United States I mean it's still a ways
to go but you know in reason if you go
back just a few decades you're pretty
much there
and they've done this by uh taking the
maximum penalty allowed under state law
five thousand dollars multiplying it by
the 550 million social media views that
Alex Jones got on his social media
accounts in the three years following
the the Sandy Hook school shooting and
now they are demanding
upwards of three
trillion dollars
from a radio host
for saying for getting a story wrong on
air
and and even and saying let's say
they're saying mean things Terrible
Things the worst things you could
possibly say three trillion dollars for
saying that on the radio
does that seem a little disproportionate
when I think
of the sort of things that the Democrats
have said in public
when the Democrats have called for
physical when when mainstream Democrats
have called for physical violence
against Republicans in public when
Maxine Waters says when you see
Republicans in public push back on them
say you're not welcome here
chasing them out of restaurants when
Maxine waters's go to Republicans homes
shout outside where their children sleep
shout outside their homes
when when Chuck Schumer says we're
coming for you Brett Kavanaugh we're
coming for you Gorsuch we're going to
unleash the Whirlwind on you and then
what hat lo and behold what happens some
left left-wing lunatic goes in and tries
to murder Justice Kavanaugh
and gets pretty close actually before
the U.S Marshals were able to stop him
when some left-wing lunatic goes in and
shoots up the Congressional baseball
game to kill the Republicans almost
kills Steve scalise
and you hear nothing
you're nothing from the Democrats when
when Hillary Clinton says you can't be
civil with Republicans
none of that they're they're not going
to pay three trillion dollars to say
nothing of what the cop the pundits or
whatever say on the air they're not
gonna pay three trillion dollars
and who knows where the three the 2.75
trillion dollar lawsuit is going to go
Alex Jones was already ordered to pay a
billion dollars
you think any for what for getting a
story wrong on it that's basically what
you could say well he got it egregiously
wrong it was the worst way you could
possibly get a story wrong sure whatever
but the actual category of of
transgression that Alex Jones committed
is he got a story wrong on air you're
telling me that the punishment for that
should be one billion dollars
or I'm sorry 2.75
trillion dollars doesn't that seem a
little disproportionate to you
especially when the libs would never pay
one red Cent for doing far more
egregious things no it's obviously not
about the transgression it's simply
about punishing dissidents the libs hate
Alex Jones they want to silence him they
will use whatever excuse they can to do
it and they will come down on him with
as much crushing weight as they can
possibly wield up to and including three
trillion bucks
speaking of the courts there's there's
some good news that's come out of the
course incredible news actually that
came out of the course yesterday in New
York
a New York judge
has ruled that the city must reinstate
the fired city workers with back pay who
lost their jobs because they refused to
take the fauci ouchy and here's why
here's the the best part is the reason
why the court has come to this finding
the court found that quote being
vaccinated does not prevent an
individual from Contracting or
transmitting covid-19
they added that vaccinated and
unvaccinated individuals have the same
quarantine and isolation guidelines
issued by the CDC
that's why
and there were at the time we were all
told by the by the libs and the squishes
we were told you have to get the vaccine
come on maybe we don't support the
mandates but you should all get it
now we find actually the vaccines don't
do what they said
what we were told that they would do and
they do a lot of things that we were
told they wouldn't do
furthermore the judge goes on the
vaccine mandate for city employees was
not just about public safety and public
health it was about compliance
if it was about safety and public health
unvaccinated workers would have been
placed on leave the moment the order was
issued great point
it was not but instead that workers were
pressured pressure still come to your
job but pressured get it get it get it
if it were about a health emergency
there's no way that would have happened
if you were about a health emergency
they would have said go home get wear a
hazmat suit get out of here
how many workers lost their jobs because
of this
people have written into this show a lot
and lost their jobs because of it I'm
I'm very fortunate I work at a company
that not only did not have a vaccine
mandate but that sued the Biden
Administration to stop the vaccine
mandate
is what were we going to do we had
meeting what were we going to do if we
lost that lawsuit well one we were all
going to get audited to the hilt we were
all going to become we might still but
we were all going to become major
targets of the federal government but
two even if that's still probably going
to happen two
what were we going to do they the
federal government could have come in
and bankrupted the company
pretty quickly actually
so we fought it we didn't have to do it
same cannot be said for a ton of other
companies and certainly city workers
Eric Adams fired 2 000 just about 2 000
city workers including cops including
firefighters who refused to comply with
the coveted vaccination mandate
now the court the court is ordering him
to reinstate them with back pay which is
absolutely right and just will he do it
remains to be seen will the city appeal
almost certainly
this is probably a little soft
consolation to the workers who lost
their jobs they've been out of work for
a year
and so it's a reminder as well looking
forward into the future
the next time we're told by the entire
establishment this is fact this is
science you have to do it this is
coercion do it now do it now you'll lose
everything do it now do it now if you if
you can hold firm if you can have a
little bit of Courage keep you
you may see Justice all hope is not lost
you may see Justice we are still in this
fight the Democrats are Running Scared
though they're they're not omnipotent
they can feel their grasp on power
weakening just now is it going to is are
they going to lose that grasp entirely
tomorrow or two weeks from now probably
not but they can feel it weakening and
and the truth is on our side and the
people are seeing that they're seeing it
more and more each day as we approach
those midterm elections now
unbelievably unbelievably
it seems that I have some critics
I reacted to some woke tick-tockers
nonsense about religion he appears to
have reacted to my reaction and so in a
full sort of Inception
I will be critiquing his critique of my
critique of his nonsense because this of
course is woke Wednesday the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
foreign